of course you've met donald trump in
person several times
how do you think he looks in the video
that was released this morning well
he's got cavities 19 he's been ill i
mean he's been put into hospital he's
been on oxygen
but considering all of that he looked
pretty robust you know it was four
minutes
um straight to camera uh he looked
pretty good i thought but look the truth
of it is
we know with this virus it's seven today
ten days in
when you really know whether it's gonna
bite hard or not so we're gonna find out
over the course of the next few days
he's he doesn't drink
he doesn't smoke he's carrying a few
extra pounds but he's generally
in pretty robust health so my guess
would be
he's going to be okay do you have any
knowledge of how the president is
so i spoke i spoke to the family on
friday um
who did you speak to i spent one a close
family member on friday
i won't reveal that and they were
obviously concerned i mean you would be
concerned
you know if anyone gets it you're going
to be concerned look truth is
we'll find out over the course of the
next few days in terms of his campaign
of course
just to just to oh there's been lots of
questions about the timeline about when
donald trump
knew caught covered and when he knew
yeah did you find out any of that from
the family
i mean look he went to bedminster for
that fundraising event on thursday
evening
he came back and tested positive
afterwards that's where the argument is
you know all i can tell you is that to
get anywhere near donald trump and
i went to the utah rally his first his
first
sorry tulsa rally his first rally in
this campaign
to even get near donald trump you have
to be tested so we
saw those people in the rose garden
hugging each other
kind of when you've just got a negative
test i guess it makes you
a little bit complacent a little bit too
relaxed um
i don't believe for a moment that he
knew he was positive until late on
thursday night
okay now you obviously know donald trump
relatively well i don't know him at all
but he does strike me as the kind of
character
who would not want to go into hospital
unless you really had to is that a fair
assumption yeah
i mean of course he wants to me you know
he's the alpha male he always wants to
give the tough guy image of course he
does so
yeah he must have had a few breathing
difficulties uh as i understand it you
know there is a whole suite of offices
at the hospital so he can carry on with
his work
look we can speculate all we like about
how well
how poorly he was on friday when he went
in the fact is we've seen him
in this video this morning we'll find
out in the next couple of days
how well or otherwise he is now donald
trump has been accused of
not taking cover seriously enough
frankly um he
mocked joe biden for wearing a mask he
compared it to the flu
he said once it affects virtually nobody
do you think this is going to change
his attitude well right at the moment
this puts coronavirus to the top of the
agenda
in the u.s presidential election way
above anything else and that of course
does not suit
donald trump because there are questions
about his handling of it of course there
are
of course there are as there are by the
way of every government in the western
world i mean they're all coming under
criticism
but if you look at the numbers
specifically there is issues in the us
yeah no no i get that so short term this
is bad for his campaign it's bad because
it puts
covert at the center it's bad because
the accusations are
that he was too lackadaisical and it's
bad because he can't go out and do what
he's good at
which is rallies campaigning inspiring
the troops which he really is brilliant
at
so at the minute it's bad but remember
four years ago
just before the second debate we had
some tapes released the access hollywood
tapes
where he said some very disobliging
things and for all the world
the presidential election was over and
yet he's the harry houdini of politics
he recovered it's different though isn't
it don't you think
no because because tens of thousands of
people are dying in the united states
they're not being able to send their
children to school
well you again you could argue that for
any country in the world um
the point is if in two weeks time he's
back
fighting fit he stands before the
american public and says look
i've had this i've confronted it i don't
underestimate it but
we have to get on with our lives
otherwise the economic cost
the social cast will be even greater
than the disease itself
if he's able to do that you know i mean
all i'm saying is this
it's very easy for commentators to write
off donald trump he disproved everybody
in 2016.
this is not over um while we've got you
i have to ask you about brexit
do you think we're going to get trade
deal i sense from the government's
language over the course of the last few
days one or two of the things they've
said about fisheries
um some of the comments from ursula von
de leon yesterday
reminding boris johnson on the
government that we did sign
a new european treaty last year called
the withdrawal agreement
i sense there'll be a compromise i sense
there will be
a deal before the end of the year uh and
it's one
that will not fully satisfy many
brexiteers
is that does that mean you could be back
into the political let's see
let's see where we go with this but i
mean if they completely drop the ball on
brexit
if we finish up stuck with a level
playing field
unable to be competitive then there are
more battles to be fought